[Music]
you are so giving me anna wintour vibes
tonight with glasses thank you so much
we're wearing gabby hurst for chloe
owning it loving it living
[Music]
she's the boss i'm doing whatever she
says that's right i feel like we are
using my care okay just by ward she's
running for president we're saying right
now
you should darling and congratulations
on season two of your show too yes thank
you so much life and beth check it out
on hulu it's so good amy now in the past
you have said that the met gala feels
like punishment so what keeps you coming
back for more
you know what i have nothing at stake
here you know not a model i'm not a
whatever
and if if gabby says she'll dress you
then
you put that [ __ ] on okay so i'm here to
have a good time and you know we've all
been locked up for a couple years so
we're here at a party in davie yeah how
you feeling post how are you feeling
post over post oscars mama you know i'm
good i'm good um
chris is good you know he's such a
badass and i'm so proud of him and yeah
i'm i'm i'm proud of what wanda and
regina and i did that night so but it's
great to see you i love you all right
and you like
knocked it out of the park amy say hi
for your time